GOING TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS --
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB THREE OH
EIGHT HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR.
AND FIRE THEM I FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO IS WEIGHING FRIESEN TATIAN
BUT WE WILL HEAR FROM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AT THE END OF THE
HEARING ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
WOULD DO LIKE.
LIVING THE FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
FOUR OH FIVE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR TODAY I'M PRESENTING
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR OH FIVE
CONCERNING WASTE WATER CHEMICAL
TAXATION.
CALIFORNIA THE LEADER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
AND AS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
BATTLE CLIMATE CHANGE AND SEVERE
IN INTERMITTENT DROUGHT
CONDITIONS WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
PLACE AND DO FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
BENEFICIAL WATER POLICY.
WASTE WATER IS AN ACID WITH
SUBSTANTIAL VALUE THAT CURRENTLY
IS UNDER UTILIZED BY SANITATION
DISTRICT'S.
CURRENT LAW TAXES THE CHEMICALS
USED FOR TREATING WASTE WATER ON
AS THE WATER IS DESTINED TO BE
RESOLD CONSUMERS.
RESELL WATER IS ONLY A FRACTION
OF THE WATER HANDLED BY
SANITATION DISTRICTS.
THERE FOR STORAGE OF WASTEWATER
CHEMICALS ARE IS A SIGNIFICANT
FINANCIAL BURDEN.
SANITATION DISTRICTS ARE
DISCOURAGED FROM STORING ARE
INVESTING IN TREATED WASTE WATER
DUE TO A BAG TAX CODE AND
UNNECESSARY LEGAL STATUTES.
AB FOUR OR FIVE WOULD PROMOTE
THE RECYCLING OF WASTE WATER BY
ADDING A TAX EXEMPTION TO
TREATMENT TO TREATMENT OF
TREATMENT CHEMICALS.
THEREBY ENCOURAGING SANITATION
DISTRICTS TO INVEST AND
SUSTAINABLE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE OR IN THIS
CASE OUT OF YOU THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY.
ON AB FOUR OR FIVE THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
UP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. TO BE
RUBIO --
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND STAFF.
MY NAME IS --
CHECK UP ALL ON I AM WITH EQUITY
RECOVERY SOLUTIONS --
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO APOLOGIZE
WE JUST RECEIVED A LETTER OF
SUPPORT WARM THE REGIONAL --
DISTRICT OF SACRAMENTO.
SO WE JUST GOT IT SO YOU'D LIKE
TO IF WE CAN.
DELIVER TO YOU --
OUR NATURAL PROCESS WORKING OFF
SERGEANTS GROUND WITH THEIR OKAY
THE SERGEANTS AT OUR SO
CALIFORNIA HAS A LONGSTANDING
EXEMPTION FOR PUBLIC UTILITIES
DELIVER TO OUR RESIDENTS.
WATER IS THE ONLY UTILITY THAT
HAS A RETURN COMPONENT OF WASTE
WATER.
THIS UNIQUE FEATURE CREATES A
SITUATION THAT REQUIRES
LEGISLATIVE ATTENTION.
PUBLIC PUBLIC UTILITIES PAY
SALES TAX AND CHEMICALS USED TO
TREAT WAIT WHAT WASTE WATER.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
DEEM REVENUE REVENUE TAXATION
CODE SIXTY THREE FIFTY THREE TO
APPLY TO THE TREATMENT OF
WASTEWATER.
THE DEPARTMENT.
DEPARTMENTS APPLICATION
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS AND
DISCOURAGES RECYCLING IN OTHER
GREENER USES --
DO YOU SEE SINCE SAN DIEGO
PROFESSOR WATER ECONOMICS HAS
RECENTLY WRITTEN.
THE CALIFORNIA CAN ENCOURAGE
WATER USE BY TAKING STEPS TO
REDUCE THE OPERATIONAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH TREATING WATER.
THE STEPS INCLUDE ELIMINATING
SALES TAX ON THE CHEMICALS YOU
ST.
THE WASTE WATER.
CHEMICALS ARE THE LARGEST SUPPLY
COST FOR THE TREATMENT OF
WASTEWATER.
ANOTHER KEY FACTOR OF FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION IS THAT THE ONLY
BENEFIT SURE OF THIS EXEMPTION
WILL BE LOCAL PUBLIC UTILITY
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES.
NOT PRIVATE TAXPAYERS.
THIS MITIGATES ANY LOSS OF
REVENUE TO THE STATE.
REVENUES MERELY BEING SHIFTED.
BACK TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES.
THE ANNUAL REVENUE SHIFT AT TEN
TO FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WILL
WHICH IS WHAT OUR ESTIMATE IS IS
VERY MINIMAL TO THE OVERALL
SALES TAX COLLECTOR.
AND WOULD FAR OUTWEIGH.
WOULD BE FAR OUTWEIGHED BY THE
INCREASED VALUE OF EFFICIENT USE
OF WATER.
THIS IS A WIN WIN SITUATION THE
REVISION REDUCES THE TAX BURDEN
ON LOCAL PUBLIC AT UTILITIES.
REDUCES THE COST OF RECYCLING
WATER VERSUS THE COST OF
IMPORTING WATER.
AND PROMOTES ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY ACTIONS.
ULTIMATELY BOTH AND ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFIT TO OUR
STATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK OF THE
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CARRYING THIS
EITHER AUTHORING THE SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. TO CHAIR
AUTUMN BURKE AND TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND TO STAFF
FOR YOUR DILIGENCE IN.
DEALING WITH THIS ISSUE AND AND
THE AND NOW AND AND AND READ.
AS MY COLLEAGUE MISTER BOLAN
STATED OF THE POLICY EXEMPTIONS
FOR THIS REASON OR STRONG BY THE
WAY MY NAME FOR THE RECORD IS
MARTY TO CASSIE AND I'M A LAWYER --
REPRESENTING --
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS.
THE POLICY REASONS FOR THE
EXEMPTION ARE ARE STRONG AND THE
LEGAL REASONS. FOR NEEDING THE
EXEMPTION ARE SIMILARLY STRONG
WE HAVE A LACK OF CLARITY IN THE
CURRENT COACH SIXTY THREE FIFTY
THREE WE BELIEVE.
HAS --
ENOUGH TEXTUAL SUPPORT FOR THE
EXEMPTION BUT THE LACK OF
CLARITY THE AMBIGUITY DESERVES.
DESERVES --
LEGISLATIVE AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD WOULD CLARIFY THAT THAT
THIS EXEMPTION DOES IN FACT --
APPLY TO PUBLIC UTILITIES IN
THEIR SERVICE OF RECYCLED WATER
AND WASTEWATER.
I WOULD SAY FOR THE RECORD THAT
WE WROTE WE WE SALUTE THAT THE
THE ANALYSIS THAT STAFF PUT
TOGETHER I THOUGHT WAS VERY
THOUGHTFUL VERY THOROUGH.
WE ARE AT IN AGREEMENT ON A
COUPLE OF ONE WITH RESPECT.
TO THE NEED TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
EXEMPTION WOULD APPLY ONLY TO
PUBLIC ENTITIES.
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT A CATCH --
THAT -- THAT
THAT STAFF PICKED UP ON WE
SUPPORT THAT WERE ALSO OF
SUPPORTIVE OF THE AT THE DELAYED
OPERATIVE DATE.
AND ASIDE FROM THAT --
ASIDE FROM THAT WE ARE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
AND THANK YOU AGAIN TO EVERYBODY
WHO'S TAKEN THE TIME.
INCLUDING THE AUTHOR CHAIR
COMMITTEE AND STUFF.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM OF
THAILAND WE CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE HERE.
ROOM HERE TOO GRAY.
MATHIS MELINDA'S MULLIN
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
KING.
WE HAVE COURT APARTMENT.
SO JUST TO CONFIRM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO EIGHT ARE YOU YOU
TO ALSO JUST WANT IT FOR PUBLIC
ENTITIES YES OKAY THAT'S JUST
WANNA CONFIRM THAT ALL RIGHT
WHEN OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHEN IS IS IN OPPOSITION?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MEMBER
CORBIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION ACTUALLY WILL
CLARIFY WE ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME --
YOU'LL HEAR ME SAY THAT A COUPLE
TIMES TODAY WE ACTUALLY HAVE NOT
TAKEN A COUPLE POLICY POSITION
JET ON SOME MATTERS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY --
OF COURSE SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTIONS REPRESENT A THIRD OF
THE STATE'S REVENUES SEE CHERRY
AS PART OF A LARGER COALITION
INCLUDING.
EDUCATION CHILDREN'S ADVOCATES
AND PUBLIC LABOR IS ASKING THE
STATE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR TO
REALLY GO BACK AND LOOK AT A
NUMBER OF THE STATE'S --
S. U. T. AND CORPORATE TAXES AND
REEVALUATE OF THOSE ARE IN FACT
MEETING THEIR INTENDED PUBLIC
POLICY OUTCOMES.
TRADITIONALLY WE DO OPPOSE
EXEMPTIONS AND CREDIT AWFUL
NATURE OF THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SUBSEQUENT
CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE START QUIRK --
SO THE BILL DOESN'T SAY RECYCLED
WATER IT SAYS WATER RECYCLED
WATER OR WASTEWATER AND YOU
MENTION RECYCLED WATER AND
WASTEWATER BUT IT'S FOR WATER AS
WELL.
JUST ORDINARY WATER TREATMENT.
YES THAT IS CORRECT SO THAT'S
PROBABLY THE LARGEST PART OF THE
EXEMPTION SO I DON'T THINK WE
CAN CALL THIS A WASTE WATER
RECYCLING BILL UNLESS YOU WANT
TO AMENDED THAT'S COURSE UP TO
THE AUTHOR --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF RUBIO BUT IT
DOES STATE WATER AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE LARGEST --
IMPACT IN TERMS OF MONEY I DO
REALIZE THE CHEMICALS THAT END
UP IN THE WATER AND OUR
BENEFICIAL ARE NOT TAX BUT OTHER
ITEMS WHICH ARE USED TO PURIFY
WATER SUCH AS FLOCKING AGENTS
WOULD BE.
AND THERE'S A LOT MORE WATER
PURIFICATION AND WASTE WATER A
RECYCLED WATER.
ACTUALLY IT YOU'RE PARTIALLY
CORRECT IN THAT IN THAT
CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FORMALLY
THE BOARD --
HAS TREATED.
WHAT THEY CALL PORTABLE WATER
WHICH IS WHAT'S DELIVER THROUGH --
TO TO OUR TAPS OVER WHAT WE
DRINK.
ALMOST ALL THE CHEMICALS THAT GO
INTO THE POTABLE WATER HAVE
ALWAYS HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCEPT.
THEY HAVE NEARLY APPLIED SIXTY
TWO FIFTY THREE JUST TO THE
PORTABLE WATER THEY'VE IGNORED.
THE WASTE WATER IN THE RECYCLED
WATER PORTION.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
FIRST OF ALL THERE ARE TAXES
ALREADY OWNED WATER WHEN THEY'RE
USING AGENTS THE DON'T END UP IN
THE WATER.
SUCH AS THE FLOCK IN NATURE
THEY'RE THEY'RE ACTUALLY AS
HISTORICAL VERY OLD HISTORICAL
RULINGS THAT ACTUALLY THEM
EXEMPTED DOCUMENTS.
THAT HAVE BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR
PROBABLY TWENTY THIRTY MAYBE FOR
YOUR OKAY.
SO THERE'S A WHOLE RACK CASE LAW
THAT EXEMPTS THE FOUR O'CLOCK
ABOUT THAT YOU BROUGHT UP OKAY
THERE'S CASE HOWEVER YEAH.
SO.
SO WHY INCLUDE WATER RATHER THAN --
YOU KNOW IF YOUR MAIN QUESTION
IS RECYCLED WATER WASTE WATER
WHY YOU INCLUDING WATER AS WELL
YOU JUST ADDING SOMETHING WHICH
COULD ADD TO CONFUSION LATER ON
THE DAY THAT THAT'S A GOOD POINT
AND THE CHALLENGE THAT WE THAT I
SEE IT AS A PRACTITIONER IN THE
IN THE MARKET.
PLACES ARE IN THE OPEN IN
INDUSTRIES.
THAT THE TAX --
THE DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY.
FLUCTUATES IN SOMETIMES IN THE
WAY THAT THEY REACT AND AND AND
ADMINISTER THE LAW AND SO WHAT
WE WANT TO DO IS AND AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE WATER.
IT IS REALLY ONE THING WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A BILL WHEN YOU
BUY YOUR WATER AND YOU GET IT
DELIVERED TO YOUR HOME.
YOU LOOK AT THE UTILITY BILL
THERE'S A CHARGE FOR THE WATER
WILL BURIED IN THAT IS THE WASTE
WATER SO IT'S REALLY ONE PROCESS.
WELL DEPENDS ON YOUR
JURISDICTION.
IN SOME IN SOME JURISDICTIONS
IT'S DIFFERENT IF THEY HAVE A
WASTE WATER TREATMENT AND A
WATER TREATMENT.
FACILITY.
I THOUGHT --
SO WOULD IT THIS GOES.
TO ALRIGHT SO YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALL WASTE WATER NOT JUST
WATER THAT'S RECYCLED.
I I JUST DON'T SEE IT SO HERE'S
THE PROBLEM I HAVE THIS IS
GIVING A TAX EXEMPTION TO
SOMETHING THAT'S BEING DONE
ANYWAY.
AND THEREFORE WHAT IS THE
BENEFIT TO THE STATE OF NOT
RECEIVING THAT REVENUE I CAN
UNDERSTAND IF FOR RECYCLED WATER
MADE.
WE HAVE TO DISCUSS THAT BUT IF
IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S BEING DONE
ALREADY.
AND NOW YOU'RE YOU KNOW IT'S
REQUIRED PEOPLE PAY FOR IT ON
THEIR BILLS IT'S NOT A TAX IT'S
A IT'S A FEE FOR YOU KNOW HAVING
THAT --
SEWERS I I JUST DON'T SEE WHY
THE STATE SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
THAT.
AND BE GIVING A BREAK ON THIS IS
GOING TO AFFECT LOCALITIES
COUNTIES CITIES AT CETERA WHEN
YOU SAY THAT THERE'S A SALES TAX
BREAKS SO IT'S IT'S MUCH.
AND AGAIN THAT'S GOING TO BE
MUCH LARGER THE MOUNT OF
RECYCLED WATER THAT'S DONE IS
REALLY VERY SMALL COMPARED TO
WASTE WATER.
IF IF WE WE'VE DONE IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT WE KNOW WE'VE
ACTUALLY DONE.
A 1% INCREASE IN THE THE
PERCENTAGE OF RECYCLED WATER.
WOULD OUTWEIGH THE SAVING ON THE
COSTS THE TO THAT STATE PROBABLY
BY ABOUT SIX TO TEN PEOPLE.
SO I STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU'RE EXEMPTING WASTE WATER IT
LOOKS TO ME LIKE A SPECIAL
INTEREST AS OPPOSED TO SOMETHING
YOU REALLY TRYING TO ENCOURAGE --
I'LL JUST LEAVE IT AT THAT WELL
THERE IS ONE OTHER THING.
YOU SAID YOUR LAWYER FOR
TAXPAYERS UP --
A SENIOR WHO IS YOUR CLIENT NOW
THAT YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON THIS
BILL.
SAMANTHA CORBIN HERE I'M I'M THE
QUESTION IS WHO IS MY CLIENT I
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
CLIENTS --
THE PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT THAT
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS ARE
PUBLIC ENTITIES ONLY.
OKAY SO YOU'RE REPRESENTING THE
PUBLIC CANDIDATES EXCLUSIVELY NO
YES YEAH NO ONE ELSE THAT I HAVE
THAT WAS NOT AT ALL NO THAT'S
FINE THAT'S ALL I WANT TO KNOW
WHO IS YOUR CLIENT IN THIS
THAT'S FINE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
WHICH LIKE CLOSE YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ON MAYBE FOUR OR FIVE I THIS FOR
TEST TODAY'S ALL OF THE BILLS
THERE ON FOR TESTIMONY ONLY SO
THANK YOU.
LIVING A FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY NO WE A STRING.
OF MOVING A FILE ITEM SIX AB
THREE FORTY SEVEN DOCTOR CHOI
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BURKE A
HAND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE --
TODAY I'M A PRESENTING AB THREE
FORTY SEVEN TO CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR CALIFORNIA SO
PRESCHOOLERS.
THE STATE WIDE TO STUDY
CONDUCTED THE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FOUND THAT NEARLY HALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
HAD TO MAKE A HARD CHOICE
BETWEEN ONE PARENT LEAVING THE
WORK FORCE TO STAY HOME WITH THE
CHILDREN.
AND THE PRESCHOOL.
THIS STUDY CONCLUDED THAT
[inaudible]
THIS MEANS.
THE COST OF A PRESCHOOL WAS SO
TO EXPENSIVE FOR FAMILIES. TO
AFFORD EVEN WITH THE A TO OUR
FAMILY INCOME.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS.
UNDER.
AVAILABILITY OF FOR LAWYER
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
AB THREE FORTY SEVEN WOULD
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE AT THE
PERFECT PILOT THE PROGRAM TO
ACCOMPLISH JUST THAT.
WITH THE FIVE YEAR OLD SUNSET
AND THE SECTION FORTY ONE
REQUIREMENTS ARE CLEARLY IN THE
DOLLAR.
I THINK IT A. B. THREE FORTY
SEVEN IS AN EASY PILOT PROGRAM
THAT THAT WE CAN OR SUPPORT.
OUT WITH THE ARE.
OUT WITH ME TODAY SO GAVE --
TESTIMONY AND SAW THE NINA
MICHELLE ATTY CORD BURNED THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF A
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE A PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION KNOWN AS A
CAP -- TO
GIVE FOR MORE DETAILS ABOUT THE
ISSUE --
THREE FORTY SEVEN WHEN IT
DOESN'T SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DINEEN MICHELETTI
COLBERN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION --
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS ARE
MIXED DELIVERY --
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ENTITIES THAT
SUPPORT OUR POOREST OF WORKING
FAMILIES WITH ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE IN ADDITION TO A HOST
OF OTHER SERVICES --
TO SUPPORT FAMILIES.
ELEVATING OUT OF POVERTY --
SERVICES SUCH AS HOW THE HOUSING
CLOTHING AND FOOD.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN
EXTRAORDINARILY LARGE UNMET NEED
FOR FAMILIES TO ACCESS CHILD
CARE AND EARLY EDUCATION
PROVIDERS. FOR OUR WORKING POOR
FAMILIES IN THOSE FAMILY AIDED
BY POVERTY THE SITUATION IS EVEN
MORE GRAVE.
ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
REPORT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET AND POLICY CENTER.
I RELEASED LAST MONTH THERE ARE
OVER ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
INCOME ELIGIBLE CHILDREN
[inaudible]
CHILD CARE.
SO WHAT DO I MEAN IN CALIFORNIA
PRIOR TO THE GREAT RECESSION
CHILD CARE WAS INCLUDED.
UNDER PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
BUT IN TWO THOUSAND NINE TEN
CHILD CARE.
MOST OF CHILD CARE OUTSIDE OF
PART OF PRESCHOOL WE STAYED IN
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT COUPLED WITH THAT
THERE WAS A HUGE CUT IN THE
ACCESS FOR FAMILIES TO CHILD
CARE.
AND THE SLOTS --
TO THIS DAY HAVE NOT BEEN FULLY
RESTORED.
IN THE MOST RECENT YEARS THE
BUDGET ENACTED HAVE FUNDED MANY
PRESCHOOL BUT SOME FUNDING.
HAS BEEN RETURNED --
SOME PRESCHOOL SLOT FUNDING HAS
BEEN RETURNED DUE TO THE LACK OF
CAPACITY THIS YEAR WE'RE REAL
HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAS EMBRACED
A MIX A LIVERY SYSTEM.
OF CHILD CARE ACCESS --
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT ALL THE
SLOTS GET MAXIMIZED --
I BRING --
AT THE HISTORY OF CHILD CARE
FUNDING --
BECAUSE THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO
MORE FUNDING THAT IS NEEDED IN
THE STATE --
CALIFORNIA ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES EXISTING WHAT WE CALL A
CHILD CARE DESERT.
SO IN ADDITION TO PRESCHOOL
BIRTH THE THREE LESS THAN 5% OF
THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE EVEN HAVE
ACCESS OR CONFINED TO PRESCHOOL
OR I'M SORRY CAN FIND AN INFANT
OR TODDLER PROVIDE WHEN YOU
THROUGHOUT HAVE A AN
ACCESSIBILITY PROBLEM.
AB THREE FOUR SEVEN PROVIDE TO
CREATE A PROPOSAL THAT MAY
GENERATE MONIES TO FIVE COUNTIES
WITH LARGE WAITING LISTS.
ARE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS
HOST THESE WAITING LISTS AND WE
CAN HELP SUPPORT IDENTIFYING
WHAT THOSE COUNTIES ARE.
BY DOING THIS MORE FAMILIES CAN
IMMEDIATELY BE SUPPORTED AND OUR
MOST FRAGILE OF CHILDREN GIVEN
THE CHANCE TO OBTAIN GREATER
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
FOR NOW I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CAPCOM PRESENT.
FOR WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MEET THE
CARBON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION --
WE HAVE NOT FORMALLY TAKEN A
POSITION YET THOUGH EXPECT WE
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSE THIS
PARTICULAR MEASURE AS WRITTEN
CERTAINLY WE AGREE WITH THE NEED
FOR MORE FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE
AND ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS --
HOWEVER THE STATE HAS TAKEN
GREAT EFFORTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET.
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES --
A VARIETY OF OPTIONS TO MITIGATE
FOR THESE NEEDS AND SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION IN A MUCH LARGER
ARENA PARTICULARLY AS PART OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS AS A GENERAL
RULE -- SEE
TERRY'S POSITION IS THAT THESE
TYPE OF PROGRAMS TEND TO BE THE
LEAST EFFICIENT WAY TO PROVIDE
FUNDS. TO THESE CRITICAL
PROGRAMS WHILE POTENTIALLY
UNDERMINING OTHER STATE CRITICAL
PROGRAM SO DO APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS HERE TO SOARED MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS ON PROP --
NINETY EIGHT WILL BE FOLLOWING
UP WITH YOUR OFFICE AND I'M SURE
TAKING A POSITION SOON THANK.
ADDITIONAL ESSES IN OPPOSITION
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUIRK -- SO
[inaudible]
IS ME.
BOB. TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS IS
A TAX DEDUCTION.
OUR I AM OPPOSED TO ALL TAX
DEDUCTIONS ARE ONLY REALLY HELP
THE PEOPLE HAVE A VERY HIGH TAX
RATE THE 13% FOR MILLIONAIRES.
A MOST PEOPLE ARE PAYING MUCH
LOWER RATES IN THEIR FORGET MUCH
LESS OF A BENEFIT.
SO I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO TRY IN
INCENTIVIZE BEHAVIOR WITH TAX
DEDUCTIONS PERHAPS TAX CREDITS
AND WILL LOOK AT WHAT THE CHAIR
RECOMMENDS LATER ON BUT I'D TO
TAX DEDUCTION PART OF IT.
IS -- KILLER
FOR ME THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE --
SING NINE DOCTOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
OKAY LET ME ADDRESS --
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER AUSTIN --
BITTER PORK SO COMMENT.
ARE YOU SEE ARE OPPOSITE IS UP
NOW OPPOSITE POSITION THIS IS A
PERFECT.
BOB.
PROFIT THE PUBLIC A PARTNERSHIP.
THIS IS A PRIVATE THE MONEY. TO
BE INVESTED.
ARE BY A INCENTIVIZING PROVIDING
40% OFF THEIR INVESTMENT THE WAY.
LOW INCOME FAMILY MEMBERS UP BUT
THAT THERE ARE NO CAPACITY IS
LACK OF CAPACITY FULL OF FULL
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN NEED OF
OUR CHILD CARE THEY HAVE A ARE.
NO PLACE TO GO TO SO THIS FUNDS
SO WOULD PROVIDE THAT IS SO NOT
100% OF TAX DEDUCTION IS A
PARTIAL OR THE 40%.
OF THE INVESTMENTS THIS IS HELP
ARE YOU UTILIZING --
PRIVATE MONEY FOR THE A
POTENTIAL LEAH UP PUBLIC.
RESPONSIBILITY IT.
IN OTHER WORDS A GOVERNMENTAL
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THE WE
ALREADY SO TRIED TO PROVIDE.
A NEEDY FAMILIES OUT WITH THOSE
SERVICES AT THAT --
THAT -- THAT
ON HALF OF CURRENTLY AS YOU KNOW
FIRST FIVE YEARS OF CHILDREN
POTENTIAL.
SO THIS IS THE INVESTMENT NOT IS
NOT TAKING AWAY THE MONEY FOR
OUR FROM THE TAXATION FOR THE
REVENUE OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR TRY AM IS
COMMON THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK I
AS A MOTHER OF A FOUR YEAR OLD
OBVIOUSLY I HAVE I I HAVE A
GREAT UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
IMPORTANT PRESCHOOL IS AND I
THINK WE ALL HAVE THE DESIRE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE.
IS A AMPLE OPPORTUNITY FOR ARE
THE CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL AND HOW
WE GET THERE IS STILL.
A WORK IN PROGRESS SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS --
WERE FOR TESTIMONY ONLY ON THIS
ITEM IF YOU LIKE YEAH RIGHT YUP --
JUST A YEAH THAT WAS MY REPLY
AND AS A CLOSING STATEMENT I
WOULD LIKE --
TO JUST I EMPHASIZE THAT THIS UP.
AB THREE FORTY SEVEN IS SOUGHT A
YEP VERY US --
SIMPLY TO CREATE A INNOVATIVE --
I'M MECHANISM OF FOR THE AT
LEGISLATURE TO TEST THE
AVAILABILITY OF A PROFIT
INVESTMENT. TO PROVIDE A MORE
FOR A WAR PRESCHOOLERS AND THE
GROWTH THE ACCESS.
OF OUR PRESCHOOL SO TO OUR
STRUGGLING FAMILIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK OF YOUR
SERIOUS A CONSIDERATION WHEN YOU
COME TO THE TIME --
BODY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI AND MOVING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
THREE FORTY EIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO OPEN ON THAT ITEM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ONCE AGAIN
IN THE MEMBERS --
THIRTY THAT THE SHORTLAND 94% OF
THE TEACHERS SPEND ON EVERY JOB
OFF FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR.
IN OUT OF POCKET MONEY FOR
SCHOOL SUPPLIES.
WHY THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS SO
TO AVERAGE?
OF BETWEEN FORTY TWO THOUSAND
TWO OFF FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
SUPPORT YEAR IN WAGES.
THEY ALSO LIVE ON IN THIS SECOND
THE HIGHEST OF COST OF LIVING
STATE IN.
THE ARE IN THE COUNTRY.
THIS TAX DEDUCTION IS NOT NOT
NOT MEANT TO BE A PERMANENT.
IN FACT OUR I AM OFFERING THIS
BILL AS A TEMPORARY RELIEF FOR
TEACHERS SANTIAGO WE S. R.
LEGISLATURE CAN APPROPRIATE THE
THE RIGHT AMOUNT OFF OF FUNDING
TO ENSURE THAT THE CLASSROOM SO
HAVE ALL THE SCHOOL SUPPLIES SO
THEY NEED.
I HAVE ALREADY SUBMITTED
LANGUAGE IT TO A LEDGE COUNCIL
TO AMANDA A. B. THIRTY FORTY
EIGHT TO BRING IT INTO THE UP
GUIDELINES SO.
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS A
REQUESTED.
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL ARE IN
NUMBER ONE NINE ONE ZERO NINE
ZERO FIVE MAKING DAHLE FOLLOWING
AMENDMENTS.
FIRST OF A FIVE YEAR SUNSET ON
THE TAX CREDIT SECOND.
IN ACCORDANCE OUT WITH A SECTION
FORTY ONE COMPLIANCE SO WE ARE
ADDING THE CORE OF A DIMINISH
THE USAGE OF A CREDIT TO USE THE
CREDIT.
AS A BASELINE MEASUREMENT OF FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO USE IN
DETERMINING EDUCATION FUNDING.
OUT WITH ME TODAY TO GIVE A
TESTIMONY AND SAW MR JOSH.
BE DEL A LOCAL LAW HIGH SCHOOL
ORDER HISTORY TEACHER ABOUT THE
HOUSE AT THIS MEASURE.
AND THE EFFECTS OF A IT IS --
HAVING ONE ON ONE TEACHERS.
HELLO --
THANKS FOR LETTING ME --
GIVE MY PIECE AND SHARE MY TWO
CENTS YOU HAVE TO FORGIVE ME I'M
IN TEACHER MODE AS GOOD ON
TEACHING A HUNDRED TWENTY
TEENAGERS SO --
HOPE I'M NOT TOO INFORMAL HERE --
JUST A BIT ABOUT MY BACKGROUND
I'VE TAUGHT FOR OVER A DECADE OF
TAUGHT IN TWO STATES ORGAN
CALIFORNIA.
I'VE TAUGHT AS A SUBSTITUTE
TEACHER K. THROUGH TWELVE OF TOP
MIDDLE SCHOOL AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
AND I'M CRY TEACHING AT A HIGH
SCHOOL IN ROSEVILLE --
IT'S NO SECRET THAT ALL OF US IN
THIS ROOM HAVE BEEN TAUGHT BY
TEACHERS AT SOME POINT IT'S NO
SECRET THAT THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE IF YOU TO ASK
THEM.
WHO'S THE MOST INSPIRATIONAL
PERSON IN YOUR LIFE WAS INSPIRED
YOU THE MOST TO ACHIEVE THE
HEIGHTS MOST PEOPLE MENTION A
TEACHER --
AND IT'S NO SECRET THAT THE LAST
TWELVE MONTHS ACROSS AMERICA
THERE'S BEEN --
MULTIFARIOUS TEACHERS TREE LIMBS
CORRAL OFF A FEW WEST VIRGINIA
DENVER THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
KENTUCKY OKLAHOMA ARIZONA AND
HERE IN OUR OWN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN OAKLAND IN LOS ANGELES --
WHERE TEACHERS STRIKING THE
COULD BE MYRIAD REASONS FOR THAT
BUT I THINK ONE OF THEM IS MAYBE
A LACK OF UNDER PEACH ATION
RIGHT?
AND ALL STAR LIKE APPRECIATION
AND ALSO A LACK OF OF PAY.
IT'S EXPENSIVE --
THIS DAY IN AGE ESPECIALLY
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S ALSO TOUGH AS A TEACHER
WHEN YOU SEE NEEDS IN YOUR
CLASSROOM AND YOU WANT TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS --
THERE'S JUST A LIST I JOHN OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD THINGS I
SUPPLY FOR MY SCHOLARS IN MY
STUDENTS AND THIS IS ALSO FOR
SOME MY COLLEAGUES.
THINGS THE CLASSROOM AND AS
SOMEONE CHOI SAID THIS IS NOT
JUST -- WHAT
THE SCHOOL HAS REIMBURSED US FOR
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL SAY HEY?
HOW MUCH SHOULD BE SPENT FOR
CLASSROOM?
HERE'S A LITTLE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR THAT --
PENCILS PENS HIGHLIGHTERS RULERS
WIDEOUT BINDERS SCISSORS COLORED
PENCILS MARKERS.
PERMANENT MARKERS CRAYONS
CONSTRUCTION PAPER GLUE ERASERS
NO CARDS --
IN THOSE HYGIENE PRODUCTS WE
HAVE THINGS LIKE HAIR CLIPS
BOBBY PINS DEODORANT ETCETERA
THERE'S ALSO.
CLASSROOM SUPPLIES LIKE THAT
THAT ARE FOR CLASS USE IN THIS
CLASSROOM SUPPLIES THAT ARE FOR
MY TEACHER USE AS WELL.
AND THEN INSTRUCTIONAL USE UNDER
FOR MYSELF PERSONALLY I KNOW
FROM DOING A UNIT ON ANCIENT
GREECE I WANT TO BONE UP ON
ANCIENT GREECE SO I'LL GET DVDS
AUGUST AND POSTERSALL GET SOME
ARTWORK I'LL PUT IT UP ON THE
CLASSROOM FOR MY STUDENTS.
AND THE REASON WHY WE DON'T
HESITATE TO PROVIDE THAT FOR OUR
STUDENTS BECAUSE AS A MAJORITY
SAID WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE DOLLARS
ON AVERAGE.
THAT'S NOT MEMBERS FIRST WE'LL
DO ANYTHING.
SELECT A SPARK FOR OUR STUDENTS
ANYTHING US TEACHING IS NOT A
CAREER IT'S A CALLING.
AND IT'S A DREAM AND I WAS START
OFF THE YEAR WITH MY STUDENTS
MUST OFFER THE AUGUSTINE CLOSES
EVERY TEACHER'S JOB.
IS TO HAVE EVERY STUDENT COMES
IN THE DOORS INSTRUCTED
pI THINK MOST TEACHERS THEY STAY
IN AND RESIDE IN THE REALM OF
INSTRUCTION BUT FOR ME IN SOME
OTHER COLLEAGUES WE TRY TO GET
THEM TO THE DELIGHTED OTHER
DELIGHTED WITH THEIR EDUCATION.
AND TO GET THEM TO THE FURTHER
AND CAN YOU MOVE YOUR STUDENTS
WHEN THEY LEAVE THE CLASSROOM
CAN THEY SAY HEY I CAN'T WALK
OUT OF THIS CLASS FROM THE WAY I
WALKED IN A LITTLE MOVED.
BY THE MATERIAL TODAY --
THERE'S A SAYING MAYBE PART OF
IT IF MAMA I AIN'T HAPPY HOME A
NOBODY HAPPY RIGHT --
IN THE CLASSROOM STUDENTS CAN
TELL THE TEACHERS NOT HAPPY
RIGHT IT AFFECTS LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT --
I THINK IF YOU WERE A STRONGLY
CONSIDER THE BILL IS BEING
PROPOSED HERE THIS IS WHAT.
YOU WOULD BE COMMUNICATED THE
TEACHERS A CALIFORNIA YOU BE
SAYING SOMETHING ALONG THESE
LINES REMEMBER WE'RE STATE
WORKERS WE WORK FOR THE PEOPLE
RIGHT --
THIS BILL BE COMMITTEE CAN THIS
WE CARE ABOUT YOU TEACHERS WE
NOTICE YOU WE CARE ABOUT OUR
STUDENTS --
WE WANT TO HELP YOU AN IMMEDIATE
AND PRACTICAL WAY WITH THIS TWO
HUNDRED DOLLAR TAX CREDIT.
I TOOK THE LIBERTY LOOKING UP
SOME TAX CREDITS YOUR FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
IT IS TAX SEASON AND HERE'S SOME
TAX CREDITS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ALREADY PROVIDES FOR
NOBLE PURPOSES.
THERE'S A COLLEGE ACCESS TAX
CREDIT THERE'S A DISASTER LOS
TAX CREDIT THERE'S MORTGAGE
FORGIVENESS DEBT RELIEF.
TAX CREDIT IS A TAX CREDIT ON
EARNED IN TAX CREDIT ON
NONREFUNDABLE RENTERS AND
THERE'S A MOTION PICTURE AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT.
THOSE ARE ALL WORTHY ENDEAVORS
BUT I DON'T THINK ANYONE CAN
HONESTLY TELL ME THAT THOSE
ENDEAVORS OR MORE NOBLE.
THAN THE PROFESSION OF TEACHING --
SOME OF YOU.
HAVE DAUGHTERS SONS IN SCHOOLS
AS WE SPEAK AND WE'RE RAISING
THE NEXT GENERATION AS ABRAHAM
LINCOLN SAID THE PHILOSOPHY OF
THE CLASSROOM IN ONE GENERATION.
BECOMES THE PHILOSOPHY OF THE
GOVERNMENT THE NEXT GENERATION
SO IT'S CRUCIAL WE TEACH OUR
KIDS WELL.
TEACHERS ARE HAPPY TEACHER STILL
PRE SHADED HELPS US IN THE
CLASSROOM AND AS THE DOCTOR
MISTER DOCTOR CHOICE SAID THE
THIS WOULD JUST BE A TEMPORARY
BAND IT IS NOT A PERMANENT.
SOLUTION --
AND WHY THE MONEY FOR THE
TEACHERS FOR US AND WHY NOT
DISPENSED THE MONEY FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
OFTENTIMES SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
THEY HAVE SO MANY NEEDS AND SO
MANY THINGS TO TAKE CARE OF NEW
COMPUTERS NEW BUILDINGS NEW VICE
PRINCIPALS OFTENTIMES TEACHERS
WE DON'T QUITE GET THAT MONEY IN
OUR POCKETS RATE.
SO THAT'S WHY WOULD BE HELPFUL --
I NORTH TOP OF MY HEAD TALKING
SO MY COLLEAGUES MY FRIEND WORKS
IN ROCKLAND SHE ONLY GETS A
HUNDRED DOLLARS STIPEND AND
REIMBURSEMENT FOR WHICH SHE
SPENDS ON THE CLASSROOM --
I TAUGHT IN THE THOMAS UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT THEY GAVE ME
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS EACH
YEAR -- AND
MY SCHOOL NON ROSEVILLE THEY'D
REIMBURSE ABOUT HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS --
SO THE FIVE HEARD OR AVERAGE IS
IN THAT WERE BEING REIMBURSED --
SO I WILL --
ALL CLOSE WITH THE JUST MISTER
CHURCHILL QUOTE AS YOU SEE I'M A
LOVER OF QUOTES --
HE SAID THIS THERE'S NO FINER
INVESTMENT FOR ANY COMMUNITY
THAN PUTTING MILK INTO BABIES --
EXCUSE THE PROVERBIAL REFERENCE
TO MILL BUT WE ARE PUTTING
DREAMS AND HOPES AND EDUCATION.
AND LIFE SKILLS AND CHARACTER
AND VALUE INTO OUR STUDENTS.
AND THE MORE MILK FOR THE WE
HAVE THIS BEING REIMBURSED THE
MORE WE GIVE OUR KIDS AS WE GET
THAT TAX CREDIT.
IT WOULD JUST BE A NICE.
AND NOBLE GESTURE FOR EVERY
TEACHER WOULD FEEL LIKE
CALIFORNIA HAS ARE BACK LIKE
CALIFORNIA BE.
KEEPING US TEACHERS IN MINE --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR LISTENING
APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU TO SHOW INNOCENCE IN
SUPPORT.
RENOWNED REPUTATION OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE WORD WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED.
POSITION --
LOOKING TO SEE A BETTER FOCUS ON
JUST.
TEACHERS IN THEIR FIRST THREE
YEARS OF SERVICE WHEN THEY'RE
THE MOST ALL [inaudible]
AB -- WHEN
THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MET THE
CORPORATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE WILL BE MOVING TO
TAKE AND OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS
BILL AS WE HAVE WITH BILLS OF A
SIMILAR NATURE IN THE PAST --
I WOULD NOTE THIS WAS A TAX
CREDIT --
THAT CALIFORNIA HAD IN THE PAST
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THE LAST TIME THAT IT
WAS IN FACT ENACTED AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE PROBLEM A. B. H.
SHARE OF THAT. 40% ESSENTIALLY.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
REDUCE FROM KIDDER FOURTEEN
SCHOOLS APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
MILLION.
AND SO WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
CHICKEN VERSUS AG CONVERSATION
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THESE TYPES --
OF LEGISLATION BECAUSE WELL YOU
MAY BE GIVING BACK TO EDUCATORS
WHO ARE IN FACT UNDERMINING THE
FUND THAT SUPPORTS THEIR
SALARIES THAT SUPPORTS THEIR
PENSIONS --
THAT SUPPORTS ALL OF THE OTHER
RESOURCES INDICATOR FOURTEEN
ENVIRONMENT --
I WOULD MENTION THAT SEE
CHERRIES BOARD IS COMPRISED OF
PUBLIC LABOR AS WELL AS
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY GROUPS AND
PUBLIC INTEREST GROUPS AMONG OUR
MEMBERS ARE THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION ON THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
WHO ALSO HAVE HISTORICALLY TAKEN
OPPOSED POSITIONS ON --
MEASURES SUCH AS THIS I WILL NOT
SEPARATELY HOWEVER THERE'S AN
INTERESTING CONVERSATION TO BE
HAD PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING FEDERAL
TAX CONFORMITY.
AS THIS IS ACTUALLY NOW OUT OF
CONFORMITY WITH FEDERAL TAX LAWS
IT'S ONE THAT AS OURSELVES AT C.
CHERRY ALONG WITH PARTNERS IN
THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY ARE
LOOKING OUT ON A MUCH BROADER
PERSPECTIVE.
AND SO WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR IN PARTICULAR TO LOOK AT
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF A LARGER
FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY A
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
I WOULD TO OFFER THE SAME
RECOMMENDATION TO THE AUTHOR --
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE. THIRTY TWO I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU AB THIRTY EIGHT SIMPLY
CREATES A TAX CREDIT UP TO TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS ARE NOT FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS SO ENTIRE
AVERAGE.
TEACHERS SPENT THE FOR EACH
TEACHER IN DIRECTOR.
OF COMPENSATION FOR SUPPLIES
SUPPORT JUST TO FOR THE
CLASSROOM WHILE ALSO PROVIDING
THE LEGISLATURE A TOOL TO HELP
US DETERMINE THE EFFECTS OF
EDUCATION FUNDING.
LET US TO GIVE A TEACHERS A
SMALL AMOUNT OF HELP OF FOR
THEIR SELFLESS SERVICE.
WHY LAW WE DETERMINE HOW TO
ALLEVIATE THE ISSUES OF A SCORE
SUPPLY DEFICIENCIES?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK OF FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THE WHEN YOU COME TO
THE BALL.
I THINK YOU MIGHT AND JUST AS A
NOTE MIND TWO SISTERS --
LIFELONG EDUCATOR AND SO I
UNDERSTAND THE STRUGGLE THAT
YOUR TRUCK THE THE PROBLEM
YOU'RE TRYING TO FIX N<c.cyan> I</c>
WOULD SAY LIKE THE OPPOSITION
SAID THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
CONFORMITY ON THE FEDERAL.
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS
AN ISSUE HE AS YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THIS MAYBE WE MAY MIGHT MAKE
SOME ADJUSTMENTS.
IN THE MIDST OF THAT
CONVERSATION YOU MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER THAT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR TRYING.
TO MOVING TO FILE ITEM FOR AB.
TWO EIGHTY TWO MR VOEPEL WOULD
YOU LIKE.
TO OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR AND HONORED
COLLEAGUES I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ALPHA BRAVO.
TWO EIGHT TWO WHICH WOULD GIVE A
THOUSAND DOLLAR TAX CREDIT TO
INDIVIDUALS THAT PURCHASE A
BRAND NEW HOUSE.
THIS TAX CREDIT ONLY APPLIES TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS OR FAMILIES
WHO BUY A BRAND NEW HOME.
THAT HAS FINISHED COMPLETION ON
OR AFTER JANUARY FIRST.
TWO ZERO TWO ONE THIS CREDIT
CANNOT BE PASSED TO THE SECOND
BUYER OF THE NEW HOUSE.
AB TWO EIGHT TWO IS TO BEGIN
DURING THE TAXABLE YEAR OF
JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO TILL
JANUARY.
ONE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FIVE
WHICH MEANS IT'S BASICALLY A
PILOT PROGRAM TO SEE IF THAT
WILL STIMULATE NEW HOUSING.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
HOUSING COSTS IN THE COUNTRY IN
FACT THE AVERAGE COST OF A HOUSE
IN CALIFORNIA IS ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND THERE
ARE CURRENTLY NO EXTER TAX
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE WHO BUY
HOMES AB.
TWO EIGHT TWO INTENDS TO
INCREASE SUPPORT AND INCENTIVES
TO HELP INDIVIDUALS ENTERING THE
HOUSING MARKET.
RIGHT NOW POOR PEOPLE CAN AFFORD
TO BUY A HOUSE.
LOWER MIDDLE CLASS CANNOT AFFORD
MIDDLE CLASS IS STRUGGLING TO
BUY A HOUSE.
AND THE UPPER MIDDLE CLASS IS
SELLING THEIR HOUSES AND LEAVING
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
ANYTHING.
WE CAN DO. TO ENCOURAGE A
SPECIALLY MILLENNIALS AND NEW
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE HOUSE
MARKET IS DESPERATELY NEEDED IN
CALIFORNIA.
BASED ON A REPORT GOVERNOR BROWN
[inaudible]
WHO?
I MISS GREATLY.
I LIVE I LOVE THAT GUY HE WAS
GREAT.
BY THE WAY ON THE RECORD.
HE SAID REGARDING THE HOUSING
CRISIS HAS STATED THAT
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY BUILDING
EIGHTY THOUSAND HOMES A YEAR
WHICH IS FAR BELOW THE
RECOMMENDED AMOUNT OF A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND HOMES PER
YEAR IN ORDER TO LIVE CALIFORNIA
OUT OF THE HOUSING CRISIS.
AB TWO IS EIGHTY TWO WOULD GIVE
THOSE HOME BUYERS AND EXTRAS
CENTER TO BUY A BRAND NEW HOME
WHICH WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE HOME
BUILDERS TO BUILD MORE HOMES AT
A FASTER RATE [inaudible]
SO.
I HOPE YOU SUPPORT AB TWO EIGHTY
TWO WHICH WOULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE WHETHER A
TAX CREDIT LIKE THIS WOULD BE A
SUCCESSFUL WAY TOWARDS MAKING.
BUYING A NEW HOME BETTER.
AND JUST SIMPLY WORTH IT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MIGHT BE EASIER IF YOU JUST SIT
IN THE FRONT ROW.
WE GET RESERVE ME A CHAIR THOUGH
FOR WE MAY WE MAY.
SOME OF THE CARBON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE.
STAFF CERTAINLY THERE THERE
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TEN I THINK
MEASURES RELATED TO TAX CREDITS
OR EXPENDITURES THIS YEAR ALL
BUT TEN OF THEM I THINK ARE IN
THE ASSEMBLY SO WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO KEEP UP WITH THE GOOD
WORK OF YOUR STAFF [inaudible]
WERE.
STILL FORMALIZING OUR POSITIONS
BUT ON THIS ONE I ANTICIPATE WE
WILL BE IN OPPOSE IT'S VERY
SIMILAR TO ANOTHER MEASURE BY
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGARDING
TAX --
CREDITS FOR THOSE WHO.
BUT CHOOSE TO BUILD A NEW HOME
SO WE HAVE.
TAX CREDITS FOR FOR BUILDING NEW
HOMES AS WELL AS PURCHASING NEW
HOMES IN IN TWO SEPARATE
MEASURES HERE --
CALIFORNIA LACKING.
HOUSING IT'S A MUCH MORE OF A
CAPACITY PROBLEM AS WERE WE
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE AN OF
HOUSING PERIOD.
AND THEN WHERE WE DO IT'S EX
EXTREMELY ON AFFORDABLE --
IT'S ARGUABLE THAT --
A ONE THOUSAND DOLLAR TAX CREDIT
WOULD INCENTIVIZE A PURCHASE
THAT WAS NOT ALREADY GOING TO
OCCUR -- AND
CERTAINLY THE LACK OF THE IMPACT
ON THE GENERAL FUND WHICH WOULD
IMPACT OTHER PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
OTHER CONVERSATIONS RELATED TO
MAKING.
ACCESS TO MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING --
AVAILABLE --
CONCERNS US GREATLY AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I ANTICIPATE WILL
MOVE FOR WITH THE OPPOSE
POSITION ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR EFFORTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMISSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
I SIMPLY CLOSE WITH.
HOUSING WE GOT TO DO SO
[inaudible]
CAMANCHE [inaudible]
DO SOME.
YEAH I AGREE AS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR AT
ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER AND IN
YOUR CONTINUED.
PRESENCE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE ARE NOW WAITING FOR AUTHORS --
EITHER JONES SAWYER AND IS ARIAN
IN THE MEANTIME WHAT WE'LL DO IS
ON AB ONE EIGHTY SIX IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON AB ONE EIGHTY SIX
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES HAS
WAIVED.
PRESENTATION.
SEEING NONE MOVING ON TO BACK TO
WAITING FOR JONES SAWYER AND IS
THERE AN WELCOME MISTER IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN WE ARE
READY FOR FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB.
TWO THIRTY FOUR THE LAST.
ONE OKAY GOOD I JUST HAPPENED TO
WALK IN AT A GOOD TIME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
OF WE RECENTLY COMMEMORATED THE
TWENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE THE
SIX POINT SEVEN MAGNITUDE QUAKE.
REMAINS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT IN
RECENT CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
IT CLAIMED SIXTY LIVES AND
CAUSED AN ESTIMATED. THIRTEEN TO
THIRTY TWO BILLION.
IN PROPERTY DAMAGE.
ACCORDING CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE
RUPTURE FORECAST THERE'S A 60%
CHANCE OF A MAGNITUDE SIX POINT
SEVEN OR LARGER EARTHQUAKE.
IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA IN THE
NEXT THIRTY YEARS AND 72% CHANCE
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
FOURTEEN CITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE INCLUDING LOS ANGELES AND
SAN FRANCISCO HAVE SEISMIC
ORDINANCES.
REQUIRING MANDATORY RETROFIT OF
SELECT BUILDING TYPES MOST
VULNERABLE TO EARTHQUAKES
UNFORTUNATELY THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH RETROFITS
BETWEEN THREE THOUSAND AND
TWENTY THOUSAND CAN BE
PROHIBITIVE TO SOME PROPERTY
OWNERS.
AB TWO THREE FOUR AIMS TO
COMPLEMENT THE THE WORK BEING
DONE BY LOCALS BY ESTABLISHING A
FIVE YEAR 30% CREDIT. FOR
QUALIFIED COSTS PAID OR INCURRED
BY A QUALIFY TAX PAYER FOR
SEISMIC RETROFIT CONSTRUCTION ON
AN AT RISK STRUCTURE.
GIVING CALIFORNIANS TAX
INCENTIVES FOR RETROFITTING
THEIR VULNERABLE BUILDINGS WILL
HELP REDUCE DAMAGE TO PRIVATE
PROPERTY IMPROVE RESILIENCE AND
DECREASE FUTURE PUBLIC COSTS FOR
DISASTER RELIEF.
I'M JOINED BY SYLVIA SILLY SHAW --
FOR THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND
TONI BREWING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU IT IS A SPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OBVIOUSLY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
OFFICE OF CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN
MENTIONED --
THE NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE WAS A
BECAUSE VERY SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE
TO THE CITY WE LOST
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
HOUSING UNITS THE VAST MAJORITY
OF WHICH WERE MULTI FAMILY SOFT
STORY APARTMENT BUILDINGS --
AS WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AT RISK THAT WE WILL FACE A
SIMILAR ANOTHER EARTHQUAKE OF
SIMILAR GREATER MAGNITUDE --
BECAUSE OF THIS MAYOR GARCETTI
IN THE CITY HAVE ADOPTED SOME OF
THE NATION'S MOST COMPREHENSIVE
EARTHQUAKE RETROFIT LAWS.
WHICH REQUIRE THE RETROFIT OF
SOFT STORY AND CONCRETE
BUILDINGS --
WE BELIEVE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT WILL ENCOURAGE
BUILDING OWNERS TO RETROFIT.
THE SEISMICALLY AT RISK
BUILDINGS BY PROVIDING SOME
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO BUILDING
OWNERS AND PROPERTY OWNERS WHILE
HELPING TO PRESERVE SOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK IN THE
CITY.
A GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
EXISTING HOUSING CRISIS --
EARTHQUAKE OF THIS MAGNITUDE
WOULD BE DEVASTATING SO WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS TWENTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB --
TWO THREE FOUR AS THE AUTHOR
INDICATED THIS BILL CREATES TAX
CREDIT. FOR OF WILL PROPERTY
OWNERS TO SEISMICALLY RETROFIT
THEIR BUILDINGS --
WHILE OLDER BUT INFRASTRUCTURE
COURTS BUILDING CODES IN PLACE
AT THE TIME OF NEW STUDIES HAVE
FOUND THAT SOME OF THOSE
BUILDINGS MAY NOT SURVIVE A
STRONG EARTHQUAKE TODAY --
ALSO AS MENTIONED THE BILL WOULD
COURAGE'S WOULD ENCOURAGE
PROPERTY OWNERS.
TO WORKED ON THE BUILDING
STRUCTURE THEIR SEISMICALLY SAFE --
ALL THAT SAID.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE BUT
WHEN THE TIME COMES PART.
STATE FARM INSURANCE DEFINITELY
YOU LETTER IN ON HIM TO MEET ME
THERE [inaudible]
MADAM CHAIR [inaudible]
NICHOLAS.
CREATE THE AUTHOR FOR ALL OF HIS
WORK AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US THANK YOU.
JOHN DEERE BONE BEHALF OF THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF GREATER
LOS ANGELES AND THE SAN OF OUR
RENTAL PROPERTIES SO STATION
ALSO SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU AT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF RANCOR
STING APRAKSIN STRUCTURAL
ENGINEER HERE REPRESENTING THREE
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION.
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION AT ON
THIS BILL BUT WE APPLAUD THE
ASSEMBLY MINFORD CONTINUE TO BE
THE CHAMPION FOR SEISMIC
RETROFIT AND SAFETY.
IT REALLY IS A CRITICAL ISSUE
WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH HIM ON FINE TUNING SOME THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA IN
PARTICULAR.
WE REALLY ARE FOCUSING ON LOCAL
PROGRAMS AND WE THINK
ENCOURAGING.
WE HAD SOME GOOD CITIES IN
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE TAKEN
THE FIRST STEP BUT IS HE SAID
IT'S BEEN A HANDFUL.
AND WE REALLY NEED TO THE LOOK
AT THIS AS AN INCENTIVE NOT JUST
FOR PERSONAL HOMEOWNERS OR
BUSINESS OWNERS BUT ACTUALLY
THAT CENTER FOR OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. TO TAKE THAT STEP
AS WELL SO WE LIKE TO BILL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAMANTHA CORNER THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION AT THIS TIME MY
MY MEETING ACTUALLY PRIOR TO
THIS WAS IN CONVERSATION WITH
YOUR OFFICE.
MR AUTHOR I AND SO HOPE TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATION CERTAINLY
WE'VE OPPOSED PREVIOUS EFFORTS
BUT HAVE WATCHED YOU CONTINUE --
INTELLIGENCE DRILLING DOWN ON
THIS ISSUE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA AND
PREPS YOUR ONE OF YOUR EXPERTS
CAN ANSWER THIS QUESTION WHICH
IS [inaudible]
IF BOB.
PERSON IS REQUIRED TO DO THE
SEISMIC RETROFIT.
AS OPPOSED TO DOING IT
VOLUNTARILY WOULD THEY STILL GET
THE TAX.
ADVANTAGE YES SO MY CONCERN WITH
THAT IS THE POINT OF THE TACK OF
HAVING A TAX ADVANTAGE.
IS TO ENCOURAGE CERTAIN BEHAVIOR
THIS IS JUST A SUBSIDY FOR
BEHAVIOR THAT WOULD HAVE TO
HAPPEN ANYWAY.
AND AND THAT'S MY CONCERN IF YOU
WERE JUST FOR VOLUNTARY I WOULD
LOOK AT IT DIFFERENTLY THANK YOU.
DO YOU WOULD YOU LIKE ME.
TO SURE I'D LIKE TO KNOW THE
ANSWER.
AND AND MADAM CHAIR I DON'T WANT
TO TAKE UP YOUR TIME IF THERE'S
ANYONE WAITING NO NO NO NO AND
AND I THINK WE NEED TO WE THIS
IS A CONVERSATION WE DO WANT TO
HAVE SO PLEASE FREE.
GRAY I BY THE WAY I LOOK THE
SAME PURE LENS THAT YOU DO WHY
BUILT IN INCENTIVE YOU KNOW
INCENTIVE AND THEN TRY TO MEET
THAT.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT --
THE CHAT AND ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I HAD BROUGHT THIS BILL
FORWARD A PLEA FOR YEARS AGO AND
IT WAS VETOED.
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BROAD
VETO OF NINE TAX CREDIT BILLS IF
YOU RECALL BECAUSE OF THE MCO
ISSUE -- THE
PREVIOUS GOVERNOR --
SO IT PART OF THE REASON WHY I
HAD BROUGHT THAT UP AT THAT TIME
WAS CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES WERE
LOOKING AT OF REQUIRING.
BUILDING OWNERS TO GO THROUGH
THE RETROFIT BUT WE'RE NOT
GIVING THEM ANY RELIEF FOR
OPTION AND SO THE CONVERSATION
WAS WELL IF THEY'RE GONNA DO
THAT.
THEY CAN ABSORB ALL THE COST
EITHER THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
PASS IT TO THEIR TENANTS.
SO IF WE DON'T OFFER THE RELIEF
THAT IS NECESSARY I'M AFRAID
THAT A LOT OF OUR TENANTS --
ARE GOING TO BEAR THE BURDEN OF
THE COST AND THIS IS JUST OUR
WAY OF TRYING TO HELP.
OFFER A LITTLE BIT OF RELIEF SO
THAT.
BOTH OF OUR TENANTS THE TENANTS
IN BOTH OF OUR DISTRICTS ALL OF
OUR DISTRICTS.
ARE ABLE TO NOT PAY WHAT WOULD
OF OTHERWHAT WOULD OTHERWISE
THEY WOULD HAVE TO PAY IF THERE
WAS NO STATE COMPENSATION OKAY
SO BASICALLY THIS IS LIKE A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR RICHER FITS IN
THE FACT.
IT'S JUST A NOTED MINISTERED
THROUGH THE TAXCODE AND THE
OTHER POINT I WHICH IS EASIER
THAN A GRANT PROGRAM.
BEAU BUT THE OTHER POINT I WAS
GOING TO MAKE ALL SEAHAWKS
POSITION ON THIS ALSO BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S LIMITING TO SOME
EXTENT TO JUST SAY THAT.
IT SHOULD ONLY GO TOWARDS A
CERTAIN SUBSET OF FOLKS WHO ARE
WILLING TO MAKE.
THE THE CHANGES --
THE DIRECTOR FITS THAT'S WHY IT
WAS OPEN.
FOR EVERYONE TO BE ABLE TO APPLY --
BUT WHAT WILL END UP HAPPENING
CURRENTLY AT LEAST IS WHOEVER IS
UNDER REQUIREMENT WILL PROBABLY
WANT TO GET IN LINE FIRST.
IF THEY'RE GONNA DO IT --
I THINK WESHOULD BE LOOKING AT
OTHER WAYS OF INCENTIVIZING THAT
COMPLIMENTS.
POTENTIALLY THIS EFFORT SHOULD
THIS BILL PASS.
IN ORDER FOR EVERYONE TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE ACCESS. TO THE MUCH
NEEDED DOLLARS BECAUSE WHAT
EVERY DOLLAR WE INVEST IN NOW.
IS SAVING QUITE A BIT OF DOLLARS.
WHEN A DISASTER DOES HAPPEN AND
WE KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT?
QUITE A BIT WE'RE WE'RE ARIZONA
USE THIS AS AN ANECDOTE BUT
ARIZONA -- A
YEAR AGO WAS HAVING DRILLS ON
HOW TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
THAT.
THERE WILL BE FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA REFUGEES --
MOVING TO THE STATE AFTER
DISPLACEMENT OF A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE THEY'RE ALREADY
MAKING PREPARATIONS FOR THAT.
SO IF THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT I THINK THIS IS JUST ONE
OPTION WE NEED TO LOOK AT
SEVERAL OTHER OPTIONS AND
REVOLVING FUNDS POSSIBLY.
OF OF PROVIDING THIS MUCH NEEDED
SUPPORT RATHER THAN CURTAILING
THE OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE I THINK
SOONER OR LATER.
MANY MORE JURISDICTIONS ARE
GOING TO JUMP ON BOARD I THINK
IF WE KEEP IT OPEN WE'RE HELPING
INCENTIVIZE MORE FOLKS TO WANT
TO ACTUALLY PARTICIPATE.
TO VOLUNTARILY.
BUT TO BE JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR
THE BILL AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW
PROVIDES THAT SEISMIC RETROFIT
CONSTRUCTION DOES NOT INCLUDE
CONSTRUCTION PERFORMED TO BRING.
A BUILDING INTO COMPLIANCE WITH
LOCAL BUILDING CODES SO IT RIGHT
NOW THE WAY IT READS IT DOES
READ THAT --
INCENTIVIZING BUT THIS IS THE
DIRECTION I BELIEVE AUTHORS
TRYING TO GO.
ARE YOU ARE CRIED LIKE YOUR BILL
BETTER.
AND THEN LAST YEAR THAT'S COMING
BACK TO YEAH THEY ARE THEY ALL
ARE.
WITH THAT ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER NEWS
OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
AND THE TIME AND WOULD LOVE TO
CONTINUE --
OF TALKING THROUGH THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE I DO UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERNS AROUND IT AND AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT.
PROBABLY IF WE HAVE MORE LENDER
SELLS TO MORE CONVERSATIONS WILL
PROBABLY COME UP WITH OTHER
SOLUTIONS AS WELL BECAUSE WE
PROBABLY NEED MULTIPLE SOLUTIONS
FOR THIS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU --
SO AS THANK YOU MONEY ONLY TODAY
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN [inaudible]
THERE WAS [inaudible]
WHENEVER MARIE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB THIRTY SEVEN WILL
ALLOW CANNABIS BUSINESSES THAT
FILE AS SOLE PROPRIETORS OR AS
PARTNERSHIPS TO DEDUCT ORDINARY.
AND NECESSARY BUSINESS EXPENSES
FROM THE PERSONAL INCOME STATE
TAXES.
THE ABILITY TO DEDUCT EXPENSES
INCURRED WHILE THE DUCTING
BUSINESSES WHILE CONDUCTING
BUSINESS IS ENJOYED BY ALL
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES WHEN
FILING TAXES.
HOWEVER IRIS CODE SECTION TWO
EIGHTY E. PROHIBITS NON
CORPORATE ENTITIES THAT SALE
ILLEGAL DRUGS FROM DEDUCTING
THESE EXPENSES.
CANNABIS WHILE LEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA IS STILL UP FEDERAL
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE.
AS A RESULT CANNABIS BUSINESSES
THAT ARE NOT INCORPORATED ARE
TAXED AT HIGHER RATES THAN OTHER
LEGAL BUSINESSES IN THE STATE.
AB THIRTY SEVEN WITH A LINE OF
CORPORATE AND THE PERSONAL TAX
CODE TO ALLOW LEGAL CANVAS
BUSINESSES TO DEDUCT LEGITIMATE
OPERATIONAL EXPENSES.
THIS BILL PROMOTE EQUITY AND AND
THE SUCCESS OF LEGAL CAMPUS
BUSINESSES BY REDUCING THE TAX
BURDEN ON HIS NEW INDUSTRY.
AB THIRTY SEVEN WILL HELP CAMPUS
BUSINESSES IN THE LEGAL INDUSTRY
AND OUT OF THE PREDOMINANT BLACK
MARKET WITH ME TODAY I HAVE AMY
JENKINS WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP --
AND AND WITH RESPECT TO THIS
IMPORTANT BELL --
AGAIN AMY JENKINS I'M THE SENIOR
POLICY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION I
ALSO REPRESENT.
A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUAL CANNABIS
OPERATORS OF WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD WITH THE
AUTHOR.
AS WELL AS MANY OF YOU --
TO TRY TO AND MEETS A COUPLE
OBJECTIVES AND YOU'VE HEARD ME
SAY THESE A FEW TIMES BEFORE BUT
FIRST IDENTIFY WAYS TO REDUCE
TAX BURDENS ON EXISTING LICENSE
CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
KEEP LICENSE BUSINESSES IN OUR
NEW REGULATED SYSTEM AND REDUCE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY INTO
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLIANT CANNABIS
MARKET PLACE.
WE BELIEVE A. B. THIRTY SEVEN
HELPS ME AND ACHIEVE THESE
OBJECTIVES IN THE FOLLOWING WAYS --
WE BELIEVE IT WILL REDUCE ALYSSA
OPERATIONS AS THE AUTHOR NOTED
WE HAVE A VERY VERY THRIVING
LICIT MARKET IN THE STATE.
AND ANY AND EVERY OPTION THAT WE
CAN CONTEMPLATE TO TRY TO REDUCE
TAX BURDENS AND PROVIDE PATHWAYS --
FOR THIS INDUSTRY SHOULD BE
ENCOURAGED --
A. B. THIRTY SEVEN REDUCES AGAIN
TAX BURDENS WE ARE SUBJECT TO A
15% EXCISE TAX CULTIVATION TAXIS
ARE COMPOUNDED BY LOCAL TAXES.
SO AGAIN THE IDEA OF PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL PATHWAYS THEIR
AFFORDED TO OTHER BUSINESSES IS
IMPORTANT WE ALSO BELIEVE AGAIN
THIS THE SUPPORTS REGULATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IF A LOT OF UNLICENSED OPERATORS
OUT THERE AGAIN PATHWAYS ARE
IMPORTANT --
THIS INDUSTRY THE COMPLIANT
INDUSTRY IS SUBJECT TO STRICT
NEW ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC SAFETY
PUBLIC HEALTH STANDARDS.
SO ANY AND ALL INCENTIVES ARE
STRONGLY THESE REASONS THE
SUPPORT DURING THE APPROPRIATE
TIME -- I
WOULD KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
QUESTIONS AMONG SOME OF THE
MEMBERS WITH RESPECT TO HOW THE
INDUSTRY WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS OPTION AND WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE F. T. B. --
AND PREPARING A SURVEY TO OUR
MEMBERS WHICH WE ARE PREPARED TO
PRESENT TO STAFF TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL AS YOU
CONTEMPLATE ALL OF THE BILLS
BEFORE YOU AND VOTE AND SHORT
ORDER.
THANK YOU I ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS
REPRESENTING NOR CAL CANNABIS
ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT WE WANT
TO SUPPORT WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SPLIT JOHNSON AIRCRAFT
TEACHERS A FEW ON A Mà HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MORE INTERNET ON BEHALF OF THE
MEDICARE'S BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
VETERAN JASON BRIDE HUMBLE
COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE WERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NICKELODEON GIVE
ME HALF OF MOXIE EXTRACTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE DOT COURT.
LEAST YOU KNOW I'M PAYING
ATTENTION.
NO ONE HAS EVER GOING TO SUPPORT
YOU'RE ALWAYS PAYING ATTENTION --
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE GO IN
THIS DIRECTION --
AND THAT YOU WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMITTEE --
TO FIX ANY PROBLEMS THEY SAY --
I AGREE VERY MUCH THAT ARE LEGAL
OPERATORS HAVE TO GET A BREAK --
THE STATE TAXES TO HIDE THE
LOCAL TAXES ARE TOO HIGH.
AND IF THEY CAN'T BE DOCKED --
BUSINESS EXPENSE THOSE TAX THEY
INCOME TAX BECOMES TOO HIGH.
SO -- I'D
LIKE TO BE YOU WILL BE THANK YOU.
THAT IS HIGH PRAISE THESE I KNOW
CHAIR IN HERE FROM DOCTOR QUIRK.
US ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE SEEING NONE I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS --
TO COMPLY WITH THE WITH THE
COMMITTEE POLICY --
ON WHAT THE FIVE YEAR SUNSET IN
COMPLYING ON THE REVENUE TO NEW
AND TAX CODE SECTION.
FORTY ONE YES SIR THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
WORK THIS IS AA --
TESTIMONY ONLY ITEM FOR TODAY
BUT THANK YOU FOR CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH US WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
BUT THAT THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS FOR TODAY HAVE A GOOD
WEEK